كيف تقيم ما جرى او ما يجري في بخموت حتى
الان مع تقارير سيطره قوات فاجنر عليها ثم
ربما عوده لاحقا للقوات الاوكرانيه او
تسليمها للجيش الروسي بما يعني ان كل ما
يتعلق بباخبوت
انه صراع يثير الاهتمام قبل فتره اعلنت
قوه فاجنر سيطرتها على بخموت وقبلها كانت
اوكرانيا قد اعلنت استعاده جزء كبير منه
وقبل ذلك بشهور كنا ننتظر وان تحكم قوات
الاتحاد الروسي سيطرتها تماما عليها لكن
وقتها توغل الاوكرانيون ضد ما نصحتهم به
قياده حلف شمال الاطلس والبنتاجون وعموما
ايا كان الوضع هناك فانه من الصعب الجزم
بانهم تخلوا عن المدينه بصفه نهائيه هم
يناورون في القتال وحتى لو كلفهم ذلك
الكثير ويترجم تقدمهما السابق مع ان يصمود
والبطوله وحتى الان يكلف ذلك الكثير من
حياه الناس من الجانبين لكن الاوكرانيين
حقيقه لم يظهروا اي نوعا من التراجع وهو
ما يمكن ان يكون الرساله التي يبعثون بها
قبل الهجوم الموعود والذي بدا في اعتقد
اذا قارنا معركه باخ موت بتلك التي وقعت
في خاركيف وخرسون العام الماضي بماذا
تختلفان عن بعضهم البعض
والعشرين من فبراير العام الماضي عندما
بدا القصف والخاركيف كما تعلمون موقع مميز
جدا مع محاذاتها المباشره للحدود الروسيه
كما انها ثاني اهم مدن اوكرانيا وهي مقر
لشركات كبيره في ميدان البيك تاك ولجامعات
كبرى تضم الكثير من الشباب اليافعيين
وصناعات عديده
لقد كان الاوكرانيون نشيطين جدا جدا في
الذود عنها ومع انها وقتها لم يلجا
الاوكرانيون الى الكثير من القتال والبعض
قال انهم كانوا يناورون فيما قال اخرون
انهم تراجعوا فانني اعتقد ان التعامل
القوات الروسيه معها على مستوى استراتيجي
كان على اساس انها لم تكن ضروريه في تلك
الفتره مثل ما هي عليه الان
فيما يتعلق بخرسون لقد كانت على مستوى
مختلف تماما من حيث القيمه الاستراتيجيه
فهي تقع في قلب ما اصبح العالم يعرفه تحت
اسم جسر الاسد الذي يربط القرم بمناطق
اخرى مثل زابوريا
التي لروسيا حاجه ماسه للاحتفاظ بها بما
يدع ايديهم على كل بحر ازف وايضا السيطره
على منطقه شاسعه من الصناعات والزراعات
لذلك فمن المحتمل بل ويمكننا ان نتوقع
جميعا بان خرسون ستكون هدفا للقوات
الاوكرانيه ومع اننا لا نعلم حجم المجهود
الذي ستبذله هناك لكن اخذا بعين الاعتبار
ما اظهروه منذ العام الماضي يمكن القول ان
الروس سيواجهون تحديات هناك للاحتفاظ
بسيطرتهم عليها